pretty much everyone knows who sauron is
for a while however
this iconic villain took on another
persona the necromancer of dog goldur
but why did this happen and how did his
rule over the hill of sorcery come to an
end
this is sauron's guys as the necromancer
explained
sauron may be best known for his role in
the war of the ring
but his history stretches back to the
beginning of time itself
and it's important to know his full
history if you want to fully understand
his role as the necromancer
in the beginning sauron is an angelic
being named mairon the admirable
after the world is created mayron
becomes one of the followers of the dark
lord morgoth
known at the time as gore thor sauron
serves morgoth throughout the first
age which ends with his master's fall
during the cataclysmic war of wrath
during the second age sauron picks up
the mantle of dark lord for himself
and sets in motion his plan to dominate
middle earth
rather than waging open war however he
first tries to beguile the elves
by putting on a handsome physical form
and befriending them under the name
anatar
the lord of gifts during this time
sauron helps the elves forge
most of the rings of power but disguise
falls away when the dark lord forges the
one ring in secret
hoping to control the elves who wear the
rings of power
when sauron creates the one ring the
elves become aware of his betrayal
and hide the rings away including the
powerful three rings which sauron had no
hand in creating
furious that his carefully laid plans
have amounted to nothing
sauron gathers his servants and declares
open war on all of the free peoples of
middle earth
over the next 1500 years sauron conquers
most of middle earth
and reclaims most of the rings of power
choosing to then redistribute them to
the races he believes will be easier to
control
namely men and dwarves although the
dwarves prove surprisingly resistant to
the power of the rings
the men do not and soon after sauron's
nazgul are born
during this era middle earth's noblest
and most powerful men
are the numenoreans who hail from the
island nation of numenor
eventually a vast numenorian army sails
east to aid the elves and put an end to
sauron's rule over middle-earth
faced with inevitable defeat sauron
concocts a new plan
and surrenders willingly to the
numenoreans who take him back to their
homeland as a prisoner
during his time on numenor however
sauron corrupts the king
and persuades him to invade the undying
lands this goes badly
to say the least and numenor itself is
sunk beneath the sea
when numenor sinks sauron goes down with
it losing his physical form for the
first time
but his spirit doesn't die instead it
returns to the mainland
and takes a new shape the silmarillion
explains that
once back in mordor sauron brooded in
the dark until he had wrought for
himself a new shape
and it was terrible for his fair
semblance had departed forever when he
was cast into the abyss at the drowning
of numenor
unfortunately for sauron it turns out
that he wasn't the only survivor of the
numenorean catastrophe
a group of numenoreans known as the
faithful managed to escape in their
ships having decided not to join the
invasion of valinor
arriving in middle-earth the faithful
set up two sister kingdoms
arnor in the north and gondor in the
south
seeking justice against sauron the
exiled numenoreans joined forces with
the elves and dwarves of middle earth
sparking the conflict known as the war
of the last alliance
the free armies win a number of
successes against sauron and eventually
lay siege to mordor itself
during the final battle isildur prince
of the faithful
cuts the one ring from sauron's hand and
with this
the second age of middle-earth comes to
an end and the dark lord's shapeless
spirit takes flight once more
sauron is absent from the history books
of the early third age
the appendix to the return of the king
succinctly explains that during this
time
sauron slept and the one ring was lost
when he next appears sauron is known
only as the necromancer
a name that has a great deal of
significance to tolkien's writings
by this point sauron has taken on a
number of shapes forms and names
the necromancer persona however is
distantly connected to the earliest
version of tolkien's arch villain
in the earliest versions of the stories
that would later appear in the
silmarillion
one of morgoth's chief lieutenants is
tevildau the so-called prince of cats
over time as tolkien characteristically
rewrote his narrative many times
the character was eventually replaced by
a being named thu
who is described as a magician a
sorcerer and a werewolf
he's also the earliest clearly
identifiable version of sauron in
tolkien's mythos
interestingly it's this early
underdeveloped and eventually abandoned
iteration of sauron that is the most
closely aligned with his later
appearance as the necromancer
in fact tolkien's posthumously published
book the lays of belarian
even refers to thu this way explaining
in glamory that necromancer held his
hosts of phantoms and of wandering
ghosts
so why does the power hungry dark lord
ultimately become associated with the
title of the necromancer at this point
in his story
the answer seems to lie in tolkien's
simple desire to connect his first
wildly successful book the hobbit to his
larger
than private mythology according to
tolkien himself
the necromancer was a necessary peril
who added depth to bilbo baggins world
in a letter to his publisher tolkien
explained that the presence of the
terrible
is i believe what gives this imagined
world its very similitude
a safe fairyland is untrue to all worlds
initially the necromancer was meant only
as a veiled reference to sauron himself
who was unknown to the public at the
time but his identity revealed itself as
the hobbit nudged a little closer to the
world of tolkien's other works
in another letter tolkien writes mr
baggins began
as a comic tale among conventional and
inconsistent grimm's fairy tale dwarfs
and got drawn into the edge of the
legendarium so that even sauron the
terrible peeped over the edge
but the hobbit was never supposed to
have been consistently integrated
with the stories of the silmarillion
meaning tolkien appears to have thrown
the character in
as a half thought out tip of the hat for
his own personal amusement
then he wrote the lord of the rings
however and everything changed
with sauron in the one ring taking
center stage for the sequel
it suddenly became important to
reconcile the necromancer of mirkwood
with morgoth second in command
sauron in the appendix to the return of
the king
sauron's re-emergence is first mentioned
roughly 1050 years into the third age
at which time a shadow falls on
greenwood and men begin to call it
merkwood
this is not the greenwood although
the very air of the forest is heavy with
illusion
over the next 2000 years sauron slowly
builds his power
and attempts to take a new form
tolkien's details are very scarce during
this time
and there's some contention regarding
whether he succeeds in taking on a
physical shape at this point
while it's possible that the necromancer
is spiritual in nature however
it's worth pointing out that sauron is
mentioned as having a physical body in
the novel version of the lord of the
rings
so he seems to have taken shape
eventually still
physical former no the necromancer has
little trouble sewing chaos in middle
earth from behind the scenes
fifty years after sauron's shadow was
first felt in merkwood
the wizards arrive in middle earth with
the express purpose of resisting the
resurgent darkness
over the next few centuries several
events begin to unfold
setting into motion sauron's final
return in southern merkwood the elvish
city of aman lok
becomes dogudur the hill of sorcery
and it's assumed by many that a
ringwraith or some other nameless evil
has taken up residence there
meanwhile easterlings begin to push
westward displacing local settlers
these corrupted men used to serve sauron
and their arrival gives their old master
some local muscle to man his new
fortress
this also seems to be what causes the
hobbits who live just west of merkwood
to migrate further west over the misty
mountains and settle in the shire
by the 1300th year of the age the will
have officially returned and
evil is beginning to stir pretty much
everywhere
then roughly 1 600 years into the third
age
a sickness called the great plague
devastates middle earth
in the return of the king tolkien writes
that the plague came with dark winds out
of the east
and also points out that later it was
noted that these things happened
even as the shadow grew deep in mirkwood
and many evil things reappeared
signs of the arising of sauron about a
thousand years after sauron relocates to
dolgodur
several of his enemies begin to suspect
that the dark lord himself is hiding in
murkwood
rather than a lone ringwraith as a
result gandalf the gray decides to go
and investigate
the necromancer however isn't ready to
reveal himself
when gandalf arrives in dolgodur sauron
opts to flee for the time being
so that the grey wizard doesn't discover
who he really is
the dark lord withdraws far into the
eastern regions of middle earth
in the meantime the western portion of
the continent enjoys a 400 year stretch
of peace and quiet known as the watchful
peace
during this time sauron continues to
prepare from afar
and his servants in earth remain
relatively quiet
at the end of the watchful peace sauron
returns to dougaldore
with greater power and more servants in
tow coincidentally just three short
years later
gollum happens to stumble on the one
ring and the white council is officially
formed to fight the growing shadow in
middle earth
for almost 500 years both the white
council and the necromancer by their
time
eventually gandalf returns to dog guldur
in search of answers
this time he discovers that the
necromancer really is sauron
that the dark lord is gathering together
the rings of power
and that he's desperately searching for
the one ring gandalf also learns that
the enemy is trying to locate and hunt
down the heirs of his silder
doubt evernote the room has reached
the heir of newman still lives gandalf
also runs into thorin's father
thrain at this point and the captured
dwarven king gives him a map of erebor
as well as the key that bilbo later uses
to unlock the secret door to the lonely
mountain
equipped with this new knowledge gandolf
urges the white council to attack the
necromancer stronghold
saruman the white however delays the
assault insisting that the loss of the
one ring means that sauron isn't a real
threat to middle earth
saruman isn't actively aiding sauron at
this point but the white wizard wants to
observe the dark lord's movements
in the hopes that he'll find out where
sauron thinks the one ring is
so he can find and claim it for himself
zaruman's scheming sets back the white
council's attack by several decades
until in the same year that the events
of the hobbit take place
they finally attacked the necromancer in
dulgaldur
the fighting isn't described in any of
tolkien's works and it's unsure whether
the council took on sauron alone
or whether the attack was more of a
full-scale battle
details aside the necromancer appears to
be defeated
and retreats only to later reappear in
mordor
safely ensconced in his ancient home he
finally
openly declares himself as none other
than the dark lord sauron
soon after the war of the rings begins
frodo baggins comes into possession of
the one ring
and sauron the deceiver is defeated once
and for all
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one